hey I was going bros my name is Peter
Pan I'm so excited because rebel mode
which is basically me and a bunch of
awesome youtubers let's let's show their
beautiful faces have partnered up with
Humble Bundle to support the charity
crisis text line I'm so excited because
it's an amazing charity over 65 million
only in America suffer from mental
illness whether it's from depression
anxiety homophobia bullying eating
disorders suicidal thoughts the crisis
techline supports these people they
offer 24-hour support in the US for
people with mental problems I think it's
brilliant it's a brilliant charity so
you bros and everyone it's coming
together to support these people in
crisis you could either volunteer to
become a crisis counselor you could
donate to support the charity directly
or you can just buy games so Humble
Bundle has a bunch of games unlocked
we got disco dodgeball nidhogg choice
chamber golf with your friends skull
girls spelunky and rogue lands and
rocket League you can pay whatever you
want for these games and choose what
goes to the developer and what shows to
go to the charity and if you pay more
than $15 you unlock rocket League you
can basically get all these games for
whatever price you want and support
charity I think that's amazing there's
no reason not to go and check out this
link I think we can really make a
difference in an awesome way and this is
it I'm so excited
and its promise we're gonna do a bunch
of live streams the first weigh-in is on
Wednesday July 13 with Jack and Ken I
might be there as well who knows second
one is Friday July 15 it's gonna be me
and quibble and probably cry and some
other people tell cry he needs to join
Sunday it's just gonna be just me baby
Wednesday it's gonna be jelly Cabos logo
the full schedule is down below I'm
gonna definitely be streaming the
fifteens
the 17 and the 24 I strongly recommend
that you check out the link to the
Humble Bundle and the crisis tech line
in the description hashtag rebel for
good post that everywhere let the
good people know about rebel mode
finally doing something we've been
sitting on our asses for way too long
and
that's it make sure you catch the live
streams all the info is in the
description what time what date I think
it's gonna be an awesome time we're just
hang out well it will be live I'm so
excited for this check out the link in
the description start donating get the
Humble Bundle let's do this I press see
you in the livestream and as always stay
awesome bros